The Ukrainian government says
its forces are gaining momentum
and taking back
territory amid fierce fighting along
the south and eastern front lines.
Key claims its troops
have recaptured a string of Russian
occupied villages
along the Donetsk separates
your region border.
Fred Pleitgen joins us now
live from Zachary.
Fred, good to have you with us.
How are we managed to verify
just what's been recaptured
by the Ukrainian authorities
and the forces,
or is it just their word for now?
Well, there are certain areas
that we have actually been able to verify
or at least geo locate
where those areas are.
But we've seen some videos
of Ukrainian troops marching
or going into villages,
going into buildings in some villages
and raising the Ukrainian flag.
And a lot of that,
Julia, seems to be happening
in the sort of southeastern
part of the front
from where
a lot of those
offensive actions
of the Ukrainian military
have been taking place.
And what we've heard
is that
they're sort of marching
southward from those areas,
apparently trying to break through
Russian defenses.
Quite interesting.
We haven't really heard anything yet
from officially
from the Russian defense ministry.
But there's Russian
military bloggers
who usually are very
well informed, who talk directly
to Russian units,
who say that they are quite concerned
about the situation
on that part of the front line.
And they also say that in that area,
the Ukrainians are advancing.
Nevertheless,
there do seem to be
some significant losses
also on the part of the Ukrainians.
The front line is, of course, very long.
And in some places, the Ukrainians,
the Russians have said
that they have been able
to hold Ukrainian advances up
and destroy
a lot of armor,
including Western donated armor,
speaking about
leopard to main
battle tanks
provided by the Germans,
but also, for instance,
open source intelligence indicates
some 16 Bradley Infantry
fighting vehicles, of course, provided
by the United States.
That's a large chunk of the vehicles
that the Ukrainians
got from the from the U.S.
So it seems as though
the Ukrainians are making gains,
but those gains certainly
are coming at a price.
And,
you know, the big question on the ground,
of course, has been
whether or not
this is really the big counter offensive
that the Ukrainians
have been talking about.
Certainly
there were some indications
by the Ukrainian president this weekend.
However,
there was also a video
that was put out by the head
of the Defense
Intelligence Agency here of this country
where he was just sitting in his chair
for several seconds.
And then a sort of writing
came on the screen saying,
plans, love, silence.
So the Ukrainians continuing to say
if this is the big offensive,
they certainly aren't
willing to talk about it.
But it is pretty clear, Julia, that along
pretty much the entire
front line here in Ukraine,
the Ukrainians have the initiative,
while the Russians aren't
making any gains really significantly
in any areas that we can see.
If we look, for instance, at Bamford,
which of course, is a town
that has seen a great deal
of fighting over the past
couple of months,
there are also the Ukrainians
right now
are saying that they are the ones
who are making significant
gains on the battlefield
while the Russians
are the ones who are pulling back. Julia.
But to your point,
certainly the Ukrainians
not giving any further information
about away about what's going on.
Fred Pleitgen there in south
Russia for us, thank you
Ukraine says Russia
is on the defensive
when it comes to fighting around Zakariya
and her son.
This comes
as Ukrainian
armed forces
liberated villages
along the eastern front lines.
Ukraine's deputy defense minister
says three villages in the Donetsk
region have been recaptured.
And Russian
military bloggers are warning
its forces
should, quote, expect the pressure
to intensify soon.
Meanwhile, Ukrainian officials say water
levels are receding in parts
of a neat pro rivers, West Bank.
But nearly 50
settlements are still flooded.
It's been nearly a week
since the Nova Kovar backed dam
collapsed, unleashing a torrent of water
into surrounding areas.
Clare Sebastian
joins us now
to discuss these stories
that obviously Ukraine is keen to garner
momentum and early successes
in this counteroffensive.
We're hearing about three villages
being liberated.
Obviously,
this extreme operational silence
from key, though, about the future plans.
What do we know at this stage?
Well,
I think all
we can tell
from the location of these villages
is that it could potentially fit
with the strategy
that we've been discussing now
for several weeks,
if not months of essentially.
And if we can pull up the map again
to show it.
But cutting in half Russia's
gains so far.
And if you look at where that is, just
just at the top of that
front line by Russia
occupies in the red there.
That is really the narrowest
strip linking Ukrainian
controlled territory
with the Sea of Azov.
So possibly
fits with that strategy
of cutting off the land bridge to Crimea.
I think the other thing to bear in
mind here
is it's
not just there
what we're seeing fighting
with the pockets
of fighting around Bermuda.
There's evidence further up,
even experience,
which is pretty much
the northernmost part
of the eastern front line.
Either
they're keeping them guessing
or perhaps there's
still some probing activity.
But I think that is key to understand.
This isn't as of now
a localized counter-offensive
like we saw in the Kiev
region in the spring of 20, 22,
like we saw in Harkis last autumn.
It's over a widespread area.
But this is hard.
This is a hard fight for Ukraine.
We're hearing from Open-Source
intelligence firm,
a Dutch one called Oryx,
that they've lost
16 US supply downed
vehicles Bradleys
in the last several days.
They say that's about 15%
of what the US is supplied in total
in terms of those Bradleys.
Russia has overall,
according to the firm,
lost much more equipment
over the course of this war.
But Russia is making
a lot of these attacks
on Western equipment
and Ukrainian
strongholds of equipment
and forces in general.
So, you know,
military analysts will tell you
much harder to attack than defend,
certainly in terms of losses
And in President Zelensky's
Sunday night address,
he said that
the ICC has begun
its probe of the disaster.
What will that involve
Yeah, we don't know yet.
We haven't been on to confirm this
with the ICC itself.
But but Zelensky is saying
that this was on the request of Ukraine
by the prosecutor's office
that officials have already visited
the site.
We need to try to understand
what the parameters
of the investigation are,
whether it's a war crimes investigation.
We know that the Geneva Convention covers
the destruction of installations
that unleash damaging forces.
They feel that can include them.
So that might
be part of the investigation,
but we don't know yet.
Meanwhile, as you say, a week on,
they're still doing rescue efforts.
Thousands of people have been evacuated.
Ukraine has even,
as even said, it's evacuated
more than 100 people
from the Russian
side,
the Russian occupied side of the
river, and,
of course, the environmental catastrophe
still unfolding.
ClassPass Bastion,
as always, thank you so much.